ces images ont été captées à la
frontière avec la Roumanie le long du
fleuve du Danube on peut y apercevoir
les ports fluviaux Ukrainiens disent
mais réunis en proie aux flammes tous
deux la cible de bombardements russes et
dix derniers jours
deux sites devenus la principale voie de
sortie des produits agricoles Ukrainiens
depuis que Moscou a mis fin à l'accord
qui permettait à Kiev d'exporter ses
céréales en dépit de la guerre dans une
allocution volody mirzelenski accuse les
Russes de menacer la sécurité
alimentaire mondiale
il est très important que le monde ne
s'habitue pas à la terreur russe chaque
phrase que nous subissons nous concerne
tous l'Ukraine mais aussi tous ceux dans
le monde dans la stabilité est menacée
par la Russie qui est en train de
détruire nos ports et nos
infrastructures
ces ports fluviaux sont dans la région
d'Odessa impossible pour l'heure de
savoir avec exactitude l'ampleur des
dégâts mais plusieurs infrastructures
seraient endommagées dont des hangares
de céréales des bâtiments administratifs
et des entrepôts impossible non plus de
mesurer à quel point les exportations
céréalières sont affectées car ces sites
ont un caractère stratégique pour les
autorités ukrainiennes qui en
restreignent l'accès avant d'attaquer
les ports du Danube les forces russes
avaient mener des frappes ces dernières
semaines sur les portes Ukrainiens de la
mer Noire en particulier celui de dessin